after the chaos of October CNBC debate
the newly cult Republican field met last
night in Milwaukee to focus on ideas but
where the Fox Business moderator is able
to get straight answers from the
candidates on important issues reasontv
sucked out the hot air and drilled down
to the substance to give you the top
three worst invest moments of the third
GOP debate coming in with the third best
moment of the night was Rand Paul who
finally came out of his debate
hibernation to cast a shadow on the gops
Warhawk faction you can be strong
without being involved in every civil
war around the world it wouldn't arm our
enemies I wouldn't arm Isis even the
Donald kind of sort of defended rant
though mostly because he wanted to
attack Jeb Bush I read about the rebels
nobody even knows who they are we have
to get smart we can't continue to be the
policeman of the world but the rest of
the field gave the third worst moment of
the debate launching a barrage of
promises to keep the bombs flowing in
the boots grounded I know that the world
is a safer and better place when America
is the strongest military power on in
the world no matter the lives lost or
the money spent Barry we have to make
our military bigger better stronger than
ever before we have to be involved we
should have a no-fly zone in Syria the
Kurds have asked us to arm them for
three years we're not I would in the
Ukraine Armed the people there and I
might also put in a few more thousand
troops into Germany Jordan we want the
King to reign for a thousand years won
handily must have the strongest military
on the face of the planet and everyone
has to know it coming in at number two
among the Knights best moments with the
candidates focus on simplifying the tax
code so that it doesn't favor wealthy
politically connected organizations I'm
gonna fight as hard as I can to make
sure that we should power away from
Washington simplify the tax code to spur
economic activity in this country there
are more words in the IRS code then
there are in the Bible you have to strip
the corruption out of the tax code to
pay for it you have to know where every
single dollar is being spent
unfortunately that bit of sanity was
balanced out by a fresh round of crazy
about immigrants which provided the
debate second worst moment the war will
be built and if you think walls don't
work all you have to do is ask Israel
and
we'll say the politics of it would be
very very different if a bunch of
lawyers or bankers were crossing the Rio
Grande or if a bunch of people with
journalism degrees were coming over and
driving down the wages in the press the
best moment of the night came with the
Republicans forceful arguments against
crony capitalism and the growth in
government that fuels it well first
Obamacare has to be repealed it is crony
capitalism at its worst the candidates
pitched an end to government that picks
winners and losers the truth is the rich
do great with big government they get in
bed with big government the big banks
get bigger and bigger and bigger under
dodd-frank and community banks are going
out of business and it hurts the poor in
the middle class much more than does the
rich climate can a plank percent
reduction in carbon emissions and it
isn't because of cylindrica the central
planners in Washington DC and finally
batting cleanup with the worst face palm
of the debate was Ohio Governor John
Kasich whose vision of presidential
leadership is to abandon all principle
and reason during times of crisis when a
bank is ready to go under and depositors
are getting ready to lose their life
savings you just don't say we believe in
philosophical concerns philosophy
doesn't work when you run something